ich mache mir platin haare komplett weiß
man liest dienstag
manchmal fragen nicht beantwortete
befreundet und damit herzlich willkommen
meine damen und herren zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal meine stimme jetzt
an dem start weg ein paar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
allerdings sollte heute nicht um fußball
oder keine ahnung was gehen meine damen
und herren sondern sandra und ich
reagieren heute mal wieder auf hilft mir
das ist eine katastrophe der
katastrophen auf deutsch gesagt ja und
das ist eine kirche aber darum geht es
nicht sondern es geht heute um
außerirdische gelüste mein freund ist
ein alien jetzt schon nicht moment egal
wie viel sagen dem kann ich auch und
legt sich dann platz gefunden mit der
ich habe mir gerade mal die beschreibung
während des videos durchgelesen ufo
alarm bei per handy ihre sie denkt der
außerirdische nano vom planeten x2 habe
sie besuchte nach allen regeln der kunst
verführt
jetzt wartet sie auf seine rückkehr und
macht damit ihr ganzes umfeld verrückt
hat werden noch alle untertassen
[Gelächter]
was geht da ab
[Musik]
was ist also schon wieder für eine
komplette scheiße nicht sechs grad
ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig
[Musik]
abonniert hat die sie von ebenfalls
sogar auf deutsch gesagt ist so dick
warte mal ist dass ihre worte die
schreibtische vorne und hinten und vorne
sorgen so einen lauf step gerät
außergewöhnliche träume wie zum beispiel
bernie einen hatte sind als symbol zu
verstehen wartet die frau heißt bernie
ja welche frau heißt denn bernie altach
jetzt in bern die den bären nein denn
vom fc bayern münchen
hey wieso kannst du nicht du bist ein
spieler beim fc bayern münchen man kann
versuchen sie zu deuten aber das ist
sehr individuell
[Musik]
danke dir auch noch einen freud ist der
den alltag sagt besuch ist das ist ihr
freund das sind diese geben wohl aber da
sagt selber schon war die auch sie hat
nie zickzack alter eine art wie
versprochen die dazu kommen wir mal zu
versprechen um allein wegzustecken
aber sag ich mal froh dass auch meinen
abbekommen der markt die hügel verhalten
du bist doch gestern ganz allein nach
hause gekommen und dann sofort und ein
zimmer verschwunden
hast du denn der typ ich verstehe es
geht nicht mehr so ganz
sie hat das geträumt ja dass sie mit dem
alien was hatte ja und jetzt
sie denkt aber das war realität ja wie
kann man so am arsch sein frage ich mich
einfach das geht nun mal helfen ihr
alter wirklich er war ein mir und es war
so wunderschön und er sah so gut aus oh
mein gott er sah nicht gut aus
egal ob man da sind überall da alles
klar also wer das anziehen und schön
findet der hat echt nicht alle unter
tassen im schrank hat mich abholen
kommen und sie werden zusammen eine
familie gründen auf dem planeten x2 wer
hat dich in deinem leben denn so hart
verarscht egal wie viel eine familie
gründen mit dem ich dachte wohl ein
bisschen hier bimbam er das wird durch
[Gelächter]
das ist vollkommen bescheuert
[Musik]
wieso strahls oder sogar ich halte den
besten sechs meines lebens kennedy war
offenbar ist bernie war es die auf der
arbeit und ihr seid einfach ich hätte
die besten sex war des lebens und jetzt
kommen to back wieder mit hallo vom
planeten 20 uhr hat er doch nachricht
geschickt
von hast du glaub an dich gesehen oder
was das war von anfang an
naja irgendwie ist mein gehirn außerhalb
von meinem kopf gerade bei dieser folge
ist vollkommen blind für ihre
eigentliche umgebung sie glaubt fest
daran dass sie in der letzten nacht
besuch von einem außerirdischen hatte es
besteht die gefahr dass sie sich in
dieser illusion verliert und dadurch die
chance auf eine reale beziehung verpasst
kennst du luzide träumen bei gut 7
träumen geht es halt darum dass du weißt
dass du träumst also du weißt dass du
gerade in einem traum ist es okay wenn
ich jetzt hier keine ahnung in die vom
hochhaus springen blabla da bin ich
nicht tot sondern ich wache auf und
blabla aber es gibt leute die das machen
und sich dann in den träumen verlieren
und dann nicht mehr checken hey was ist
realität was ist traum und dann an den
dachschaden alter ja und ich glaube die
frau hat auch so einen leichten
dachschaden oh mein gott
sie legt ihre unterhose sein mein gott
was ist denn es ist offen
[Musik]
er lacht die ein paar zitate sind frei
nein nein nein nein was war das nein die
hat jetzt der doch nicht ernsthaft 3d
brille auf
bist du denn das wahnsinns alter bei der
karneval oder was weiß ich nicht das mag
das in der fünften ausgerissen ist
aufgerissen hat mich gefunden er hat
mich gefunden
die gavi kam alonso ab sein man muss
halt immer sagen klar hilfe blabla dass
die schauspieler gabel aber ich denke
halt auch das war zu beginn wirklich
eine serie wo es um leute gegen die
finanzielle probleme haben und blabla
einander herausgekommen sondern mit ein
bisschen dem faktor so verwegen bildung
und latein passt gar nicht mehr ist ja
es passt nicht mehr und es ist komplett
realitätsfern geworden diese ganze serie
wenn sie ihre fantasien und sehen sie
den privaten bereich aus lebt dann doch
nicht ein so ich kann die masse haben so
erstmal walter ich wütend nicht gut aus
diesem ding
[Musik]
ja sagen wir nichts mehr zu nun kannst
du endlich ich bin soweit bern über ich
glaube das wäre mit abstand die
schlimmste folge auf die wir reagiert
haben
ich finde es ist nicht jetzt so eine
folge wo man sich die ganze zeit schrott
lacht aber ich denke mir einfach während
ich fast klar das ist geschauspielert
und wir wollen die leute jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie beleidigen die die
schauspieler die die idee ja genau
[Musik]
der lobbyist von bis zu 1 geschichte ist
auf felix ich liebe nahrung und dann
will ich ja gar nicht was hat er dann
gesagt werden die laien schon zu mir uns
alles wirklich mit mir auf die wolken
wer sein geld kommt zu ihnen flügel bin
auf der wolke kommt auch mal das sind
beweise von außerirdischen die
achtjährige sind gefolgt
und er fragt wer hat dich nochmal ich
sag ist ein letztes mal die folge ist
ein vorbei wer dir ins gehirn geschissen
gab man ihr seid alles so krass scheiß
auf diesem planeten ich werde darüber
reden aus seinem alter stelle würden sei
noch nicht das heutige wieder ist alex
sauber entweder lieben freunde wenn euch
unsere reaktion immer wieder auf hilfe
gefallen hat anlass um gegen einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da und
sollen sondern ich als nächstes auf
dieses video hier reagieren
ich mag züge neu verliebt nach mixa
jimmys treibt es auf jeden fall gerne in
die kommentare ob wir auch dieses video
als nächstes reagieren sollen und
abonniert ein kanalfest noch kein teller
lucio seit und
[Musik]